from my Twitter account and that's it
Fox News filed a copyright strike on our
GOP debate commentary taking the whole
episode down and I will say immediately
as we begin the segment I believe that
what we did was absolutely fair use we
were uh uh first of all this is the
public has a right to know what's going
on with these debates it is newsworthy
what these individuals are saying we
were commenting directly on what was
being said and the show itself it was
direct commentary on this combine those
things and I think that
immediately this is a matter of our
democracy as they like to say right so
the argument would be that Fox News can
host presidential candidates who can say
things that only they are allowed to
filter to the American public and no one
else is allowed to fact check what they
are saying now their argument is you can
fact check them but you can't just show
what they've said in in real time I
reject that that would mean that
everyone has to watch only their
interpretation and it creates a
circumstance in which they can
selectively choose to take down only
specific commentary it would be
impossible to take down everyone who's
providing commentary which means there
will always be the argument that oh but
uh you know they they infringe on our
copyright so we took them down it's okay
okay hold on the guy critical of
candidate one was taken down but the guy
critical of candidate 2 was not oh we
must have missed it that creates a
loophole that will require that you
actually can't do anything about to to
be completely honest I think this
President can't stand because uh right
now as it stands I can't sue Fox News
simply for filing a claim on YouTube we
can do a counter claim and have their
claim pushed back they can then in 10
within 10 days file a lawsuit otherwise
YouTube restores our video they then
have to sue us but if if if this is
allowed to stand what happens is you
have Democrat and Republican the
Democrats run criticism of the GOP and
let's say Democrat personalities and
Republican personalities are commenting
and criticizing and then large
institution whoever it may be can choose
to only strike certain plat channels the
other the people who are not given a
strike can't sue and the people who are
given a strike don't have standing in
court to argue oh but look they're not
being taken down because the argument is
okay well we'll go take them take them
take them down next you would have that
argument you could say they're doing
this selectively but what what the
situation it creates is the only person
with the power is the institution
controlling the debates no one can fact
comment on it and they can control who's
allowed to fact check and comment it on
it that that's that's an impossibility
but I've got more news here to add to
this David Pacman 9 days ago has uh had
announced the same thing and I was
unaware of this and uh here you can see
the copyright strike he received on his
channel let me remove the uh uh remove
the copy uh the the CC the close
captions you can see that uh it no way
does it affect his ability to stream as
of right now Fox Media LLC October 6
filed the strike against him I can say
this now I'm not going to reveal uh any
P any what here's what I can say several
other uh uh individuals who are
providing commentary on uh uh on the
debates also received strikes and had
their commentary taken down it's hard to
know when you know we started doing a
curs research of other channels because
the videos aren't there so we don't know
if they did or didn't I don't track what
everybody does but uh knowing that David
did I immediately saw this video when I
started doing my my search of this and
David also received uh a strike so we'll
see what happens over the next week or
so I don't know I I I I would be I would
be shocked if Fox News actually tries to
pursue lawsuits against a combined you
know 50 million subscribers across the
board arguing that they are the only
ones allowed to have commentary I will
further add in my view and uh probably
if there was going to be a suit you know
my lawyers going be like stop saying all
this stuff I don't care this is
important the show that we did is not
even a substitute for what Fox was
providing no you could not even hear the
debate half the time because we are just
insulting
politicians if you want to actually just
listen to the words of the politicians
you go you go watch the debate on Fox
News if you want to hear us yell at them
and insult them you come here but you're
not even hearing half the time what what
they were saying so I don't even think
that argument stands Fox News is
deciding to go to war against some of
the biggest political commentators in
the world right now I can't imagine they
I think this is I think this is an abuse
of the system and uh I think they lose
on this on this one this is insane and
this is why you know initially we didn't
even want to do uh uh the coverage of it
because it's stupid because the Lesser
known Republican candidates Trump is
going to win and so we decided to simply
because uh you know ultimately there's
there's several things one people really
wanted to hear us fact check and comment
on what they were saying and so we they
were like look they didn't care what
what was being shown in the debates they
cared what we were how we were
responding how essentially we want to
debate the presidential candidates if
Fox News has their way there will be no
public debate on our presidential
candidates and I think that's that's
absurd it's like a reaction video too I
I I I can I can respect to a certain
degree an argument made by Fox but I
think it's a bad argument that loses
because in order for us to have our
institutions our our El our
constitutional republic with Democratic
institutions there must be a robust
public debate on our political
candidates and they do not have the
argument that they own the Monopoly on
the political debate if their show was
simply truckers arguing truck driving
totally get it but these people want to
be president and fox is telling me I
have no right to fact check them in real
time no way yeah it's no go ahead no
they they even went to the extent where
you said that they had a choice where
they could just take the video down or
actually like punish you with a strike
and they chose to punish you with a
strike so that just kind of goes to show
that it was you know kind of a
weaponized uh attempt to take a stab at
Tim pool for well it's not just me I
mean there's a bunch of it's a bunch of
people who got strikes they went after
they're going after everybody is my
understanding uh well I shouldn't say
everybody they've gone after a lot of
people I do have some questions cuz I I
can say they didn't go after everyone
just yet so I I say just yet but that's
the point if Fox News News is
selectively taking down only some then
the argument would be they are creating
an environment where any institution
that is hosting a debate can choose
who's allowed to comment on the debate
well we can't have that there's there's
there's no functioning democratic
election if large institutions are like
we're going to let these seven people do
it I mean I mean this I I'll put it this
way Fox could quite literally be like oh
all of those uh commentators we give
them a license those ones we take down
and it's and it's and it's arbitrary it
effectively just silos and manipulates
and controls public discourse I think
this is a a gross infringement an
egregious abuse of the system but I also
think I think if they pursue a lawsuit
it goes to the Supreme Court I think
they lose I also think that it doesn't
make any sense for Fox to be able to
have a
proprietary um broadcast there should be
anyone who wants to broadcast the debate
should be allowed into broadcast the
debate that is in the public interest
it's a it's like you were saying these
are people who want to be president now
none of them are going to be president
but they certain you know but they're
certainly out there trying to do this um
and any American should have the ability
to to see that and the fact that Fox
News is on cable and a lot of people
can't see that also is a problem but
it's free online and there's a lot of
arguments they can make about who they
allow to stream and things like that
don't care my argument is they want to
create a world where they are the funnel
of information on public discourse so
there's we have these things called
anti-s slap laws uh it's slat means
strategic lawsuit against public
participation Mo there are many states
probably half the country where if I
said David Pacman you know is a you know
leftist communist or whatever insult you
know insult him in some way then he
can't sue me for several reasons it's
not just the higher standards right you
could actually because David Pacman is a
public figure accuse him of doing a
backflip and landing in the mud and let
let's let's argue that for some reason
it's disparaging I'm trying I'm not
trying to disparage that David I'm just
doing as an example because we pulled
this channel up uh anti-s slap laws
basically shut the lawsuit down
instantly arguing that my accusations
against them are public participation
that we are public figures having a
debate in public and we are allowed to
and so it's you have what's called uh
times V Sullivan that's where if I said
someone is a uh uh uh if I said Carter
Banks kicked a dog he can't sue me it's
it's crazy because the the the uh actual
malice standard based on the precedent
of what's called time V Sullivan he
would have to prove I intentionally lied
knowing beforehand he did not kick a dog
which is almost impossible because you
you you'd have to get past summary dis
summary judgment get to Discovery
nowhere to find the statements and hope
they are let's say I know for a fact
that Carter behind the scenes was going
Mah I'm going to lie about Tim p and
claim he kicked a dog and then I'm like
I know he did it I heard him say it can
you prove it no but he said it too bad
you're out now you get that that's
that's that's times V solivan most
people are familiar with that that's how
the left is able to call everyone Nazis
and white supremacists they call Laura
lummer a white nationalist over Jimmy
Kimmel just did I mean that that may be
defamation per se I think she should sue
because she doesn't need to prove
damages in that case right defamation
per se is when you're accusing someone
of something so egregious that that it
in and of itself is is damaging anti-s
slap would then be if I claim Jimmy
kibble kicked a dog he and he sued me
over that then it'd probably get thrown
out instantly o over anti-s slap there
are a lot of states that are just like
nope you can't there he's talking about
public stuff that's going on when I look
at this I see something very similar I
think this needs to be handled by the
Supreme Court it must be and the reason
for it is the the era of the ubiquitous
live stream is new it has not yet been
adjudicated uh has not yet gone to the
courts we need to know where the Supreme
Court stands on our right to debate the
political candidates in real time when
it when it when a candidate stands on
stage and says when I was governor I did
this and when I'm president I'll do that
and we go whoa whoa whoa he didn't do
that when he was
governor if there is no public debate
allowed then only wealthy institutions
are allowed to to to control who's who's
being president it destroys public
participation in debates
so that's where I stand uh rant over I
guess but uh we we will have some
developments in the next week or so as
to what happens and I think if Fox News
does decide to take this to
court here's what I ultimately think I
think Fox News will not I think they're
going to Cave they're going to back down
and they're going to accept it because
if Fox News does Sue this will go to the
Supreme Court and they will lose and
then it becomes precedent in law and
they'll never have a leg to stand on
again thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at tim.com for
uncensored membersonly shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time